good morning Hank it's Wednesday if
you're wondering when my foots over
there it's because a couple things are
afoot anybody afoot ding 1 a class 9
nerdfighter Smike Nickleby made an
important discovery on tumblr by the way
my voice is a little bit husky I'm sorry
about that I have a call ladies you're
welcome
that discovery was that as you age Hank
you will look more and more like popcorn
magnate Orville Redenbacher so and
congratulations on five years of
marriage Katherine enjoy it now because
you will one day be married to Hank
Ville green and Bakr king to nerd factor
so he finally finished going through
almost 2000 nerd factor video entries I
cannot believe how much talent there is
in nerd fight area and I am sick that we
are only picking six winners because
there could be all hundreds
but we made our choices there are six
winners winner number one MIT and Sony I
am in something this is a video blog
also I I have no hair I look like fat
Gandhi it looked like a really tan Vin
Diesel I look like a hypocritical
skinhead okay moving on fat Gandhi this
guy's hilarious Hank and it's the kind
of like unpretentious well edited funny
authentic video blogging that I just
love also Inc that video it's like 117
views and 3 likes it deserves a wider
audience by the way my voice is not just
husky it is like an 80 year old woman
who has smoked for the last 74 years of
her life can just bring me another
cigarette I don't know why I named her
Candace maybe I'm watching too much
Phineas and Ferb winner number 2's on D
Aziz hilarious thoughts from places
video from Bloemfontein South Africa and
lo and behold two roads diverged in a
yellow wood and I well I took the one
more traveled on because I'm not trying
to get raped on some random Hill in the
middle of Bloomington I love everything
about this video I love all he took the
thoughts and places video format and he
made it better and you know many
subscribers he has Hank zero there's a
guy making brilliant thoughts from
places videos from South Africa who has
no subscribers Hank we can't cure cancer
but that is a problem we can fix we're
number three Casey conundrum song about
bizarre fruits
some countries and song roots they're
not your average I mean take some would
say this is just a song about bizarre
fruits but I would say it's the song
about bizarre fruits winner number four
Lindsey the nerdiest who had me at her
username with her rant about
romanticizing fictional characters
here's what I'm thinking the surest way
to get anyone hooked on a new book or
movie or TV series is to make them fall
in love with the character winner number
five Thomas Jefferson the musical Hank
is video access quite a few views but it
is the best musical about Thomas
Jefferson and the writing of the
Declaration of Independence that will
ever be made entry otic duties an
astounding father as I feared why the
hell are you the only founding father
with the beard
Am I yes weird thank you for announcer
last winter I just thought of something
I got a call mom I have a quick question
for you I need you to answer immediately
because if you don't answer immediately
I'm gonna think that you're lying
did you ever know and/or have a romantic
relationship with Orville Redenbacher
that was a pause and lastly relation
xiii music video for her original song
permafrost sometimes
[Music]
and hey I can't stop listening to this
and her other songs are just as good I
mean my first favorite band is the
mountain goats my second favorite band
is the mountain goats my third favorite
band is Hank green and my fourth
favorite band is now Malaysian 13 it
used to be the mountain goats so there's
a playlist below where you can watch all
the nerd factor winners if you like them
as much as I did please let people know
by commenting and liking and subscribing
Thanks to everyone who submitted nerd
factor videos I'm leaving video
responses to this video open so you can
go there and find amazing stuff made by
nerdfighters clearly I need to give my
voice to break so I'm going back to
signing The Fault in Our Stars but Hank
I will see you on Friday